it's not mine but it's my lower back and
it's really classier every holiday and
birthday I tell my husband that I'm
going to get his name tattooed on my
butt I think that when I reveal the
tattooed in him he's totally gonna
believe me it never takes me seriously
and this is probably why she told me two
weeks ago that if I ever got a tattoo of
her name she would probably break up
with me because she thinks it's a
stupidest thing on earth he could be
either really excited or he could be
horrified and relieved that it's a job I
think he's gonna like be like oh that's
so sweet thank you but like secretly
hated but oh yeah but inside be like cry
I can't feel how big it is oh my god
it's everything I hoped it could be I'm
gonna get it
so I know I told you that we're here to
talk about our first Christmas together
that's a lie you're kidding I got
something today for you and I told you
that I had a secret present then I was
putting together earlier today we had a
tattoo artist coming in and I got
something yes it is right here it's
winter so you'll be able to cover it up
with did you use [ __ ] stamp
yes yes I can't believe it no you don't
believe no I don't believe it
are you married it's just a lot to
process I love it a lot real this is
real and it hurts so stop touching haha
I like it it's just a lot what do you
read it's a lot I just was a surprise
you're crazy
oh it's not a real tattoo
I was trying to pray with you absolutely
not gonna way it's me there you prank
everybody do you know what I'll tell him
do i what if this was real
it would be awful I mean I can't recover
you over that I would have like let it
ride for a while but then maybe really
hit up the removal stop what are you
already going get removed
it's just so not you I was the perfect
setup
I totally did you know what though in
the end the joke's on me cuz this is on
for two weeks
oh so that's fun well now I love it and
then I'm thinking your mom is gonna kill
me for inspiring you to get thick